LL EST
[La musique]
C'est très risqué Après tout, quel est le résultat ?
nous savions que nous obtiendrions
mais après avoir essayé et fait
Le résultat nous a surpris.
Surpris Ils ont même dit quelque chose de si bonus
il semble que beaucoup n'y croient toujours pas
c'est-à-dire après avoir mangé en écoutant en direct
[La musique]
Nos ressources naturelles s'épuisent
recevoir des signes très importants au point
nous avons commencé tous les deux sur le réchauffement climatique
à la fois la pollution de la mer, les mucilages
nous avons eu la catastrophe récemment
nous en avons été témoins directement, maintenant la société
comme le
[La musique]
s'abonner